elle vise à vous tous je suis une petit
frère
paris
et dans les magazines
je ne lis pas ma vie
je suis une provinciale
je n'ai pas lu par m
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une vie normale
[Musique]
corrigés
quand
comme la famille et vous à la chanson ne
changera pas son
et là
voilà
vous aujourd'hui une petite française
née
loin de sous
d'enfants
la tête enfui a tenu bien
raison de quitter sans
raison pour ce tout
devant
i
[Musique]
je ne fais pas une idole qu'on avait
compte des données
je vis mes années
[Musique]
toujours loire de paris
mais sans avoir dans
suivirent pas miens jégo
quand je vois quelques gosses
que joue autour de moi
[Musique]
quand
quant à paris épouse à la chanson
ne changea pas 100 ans
aujourd'hui
une petite française néant
loin de ces jeux d'enfants s'étaient
enfuis à des libyens
ceux qui descendent
raison pour ce tout
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
la voilà